oh man it's bill bell Jack's house oh  cool  Super Bowl rings hey guys look I'm Bill  Russell Wilson Sheamus what are you  doing get back here  come on man it's just a little QB sleep  you guys I don't know about this can't  believe how easy it was a sneak in here  no it's like getting three offensive  line whoa what he's got a clone army  Gronk's no wonder he's playing every  week Goodell needs to know about this  show I intercept them mr. Bulger yes  what is office it's like some sort of  new players you see Tom is getting old  and needs extra protections genius he  could take stabs from shotgun and still  be under center you've gone too far Bell  check to that there's nobody who can  stop me oh there you guys are  sorry I'm late I took a lot of sacks oh  my kryptonite I am an A